also mein thema ist dass das thema preis
explosion eigentlich uns alle
beschäftigt das heißt es wird alles viel
viel teurer aber das schlimmer ist wir
machen fast nichts dagegen ich höre es
in meinem umfeld jeder erzählt immer
sagen auch jetzt durch diese
energiekrise dann durch den ukraine
kriegt das wird alles viel viel teurer
ich kann das nicht bezahlen aber egal
was ich den leuten erzähle es wird nicht
umgesetzt und ich glaube es muss ein
umdenken stattfinden
dass man letztendlich wirklich sich mehr
zeit nehmen um sachen zu lernen um mehr
zu sparen thema energie gas strom
wechseln jeden den ich frage
letztendlich hier auch schlecht in die
runde wer wechselt die regelmäßig strom
gas dann sagt man ja weiß ich müsste man
mal war viel zu selten das gleiche beim
tanken wer hat eine tanke wer fährt zwei
straßen weiter oder abends noch mal wenn
es wirklich günstig ist jeder kennt die
tipps angeblich aber machen tut keiner
und dann finde ich schwierig wenn wir
alle sagen da muss die politik lösen nur
mit 30 35 prozent rabatt auf eine offene
liter kraftstoff werden das allein nicht
lösen deshalb ist mein wirklich aufreger
thema zu sagen viele sprechen darüber
aber es wird viel zu wenig gemacht und
es gibt lösungen wechsel wechsel lassen
aber keine nutzen
den bürger wie auf mich etwas zynisch
wirken die inflation greift um und sie
sagen da muss man halt mehr sparen das
ist ja fast so wie dem goethe vielleicht
genau ein wichtiger punkt ich nicht ich
sage immer sparen ohne verzicht das
heißt links gleiche produkt die gleiche
menge bei strom gas ist es so also 70
prozent der deutschen sind auf ihrem
grundversorger die zahlen monat für
monat viel zu viel geld für das gleiche
produkt was der steckdose kommt ich kann
seit jahrzehnten wechseln es machen ganz
ganz wenige leute wirklich regelmäßigen
wechsel oder es gibt ja mittlerweile
wechsel services man kann es wechsel
lassen es macht aber fast keiner und das
ist halt sehr sehr schade das gleiche
bei den einkäufen klar wenn ich einfach
im supermarkt sage so ich hätte jetzt
bitte die rabatte warum ist dann alles
so teuer geworden wenn ich mich ein
bisschen vorbereitet mit einer sparen
meinen einkauf einmal auf liste zeigt er
mir an wann wo in welchem supermarkt ich
mehr sparen kann da sind rabatte von 20
30 prozent drin man möchte es aber nicht
machen klar ist es nur umstellung ich
glaube man muss mehr zeit investieren
aber ich sag mal sparen verzichten zeit
ist geld aber
ich glaube man spielt zu viel zu hause
auf der playstation home und ärgert sich
dann warum der strom zu teuer ist und da
wirklich diese zeit investieren andere
länder machen es schon mehr und es gibt
sehr viele sparmöglichkeiten nebenbei
aber es wird zu wenig umgesetzt und das
muss sich eine julian sparst du genug
hast du dir schon mal darüber gedanken
gemacht ich kann mich wirklich diesem
aufruf nur anschließen und ich möchte
mich hier outen ich bin jemand der sei
es strom sei es gas sei es damals hieß
premiere jetzt sky jedes jahr können
nicht jedes jahr aufs neue kündigt und
ich spare deshalb unfassbar also ich hab
kennen den originalpreis von sky gar
nicht mehr aber ich bezahl weniger als
die hälfte dafür
im monat und ich sehe es ganz genauso
man muss das eben tun man muss es tun
und das ist will keine supermarktketten
nennen aber einige haben mittlerweile
eine app und da kann man noch mehr
sparen und da kann man noch ich weiß man
sagt immer wenn man nicht mit geld
bezahlt man mit seinen daten so ist es
eben so ist es eben das macht jeder von
uns der instagram oder facebook oder
twitter oder was auch immer benutzt so
ist es immer bezahlt und seinen daten
wenn man kein geld bezahlt aber am geld
kann man tatsächlich eine menge sparen
und du hast gesagt zeit ist geld ja aber
was machen denn die leute abends ich
meine das ist eine halbe stunde weniger
natürlich nicht bild tv gucken aber eine
halbe stunde weniger vielleicht doch mal
netflix oder amazon
oder tv irgendwas gucken und diese halbe
stunde nutzen tatsächlich um einmal im
jahr seine verträge zu kündigen und neu
aufzusetzen und ist es bringt unfassbar
4 ist es sind also es sind hunderte
hausen tausende von euros letztendlich
dadurch sparen kann wirklich sich
immerhin sei es ist nicht sexy ich weiß
das ist halt ich sag mal wie viel muss
es noch wirklich teurer werden bis man
wirklich daran diese grenze kommt jetzt
kommt jeder an sagt zu mir wie war das
noch mit mit dem strom wechseln wo
kriege ich nur solaranlage in wo kann
ich günstiger tanken und ich glaube der
benzinpreis muss drei euro werden bis
die ersten leute dann wirklich sagen
mensch jetzt muss ich mal gucken möglich
vor sechs oder nach 21 uhr ja das ist
spät es ist unbequem noch mal raus zu
gehen aber dann jetzt nach der sendung
oder nach dem feierabend dass die leute
nach hause fahren sagen ach mensch tanke
da fahre ich wieder dran dann brauche
ich mich nicht zu wundern es wird nicht
anders gehen wenn ich nicht möchte
gebietes das geld dann entsprechend
zahle ich mit meiner zeit dafür dann
dann erlaube ich mir das dann kaufe ich
mir zeit wenn ich mir aber nicht mehr
leisten kann und klar denn die
schicksale am unteren ende immer die
schlimm aber gerade die mittelschicht
hat schreit aber macht wenig herr
fleischhacker sind die österreicher ein
sparsames volk gibt es da vielleicht
sogar regelrechte sparclubs man könnte
sich ja auch zusammenschließen zum
sparen ich glaube der österreicher ist
im grunde zu schlampig um zu sparen muss
ja dann immer sehr genau sein um zu
sparen und das ist der österreicher
nicht und ich verstehe dass auf der
individuellen ebene die möglichkeiten
gibt die glaubt man darf nur in der
situation in der wir jetzt sind und wo
die steuerung und die preissteigerungen
die inflation sehr fast monothematisch
durch den abrieb energiepreise getrieben
ist muss man glaube ich
volkswirtschaftlich dann noch irgendwie
zusätzlich überlegt sich gerade dann
sagt man ja das ist ja die politische
diskussion ist es günstiger die steuern
zu senken will westerwelle auch die der
steueranteil an den treibstoffpreisen
dieser ist der löwenanteil oder ist es
zb günstiger durch direktzahlungen denen
die es schwerer haben sozusagen das zu
ersetzen ich glaube volkswirtschaftlich
haben wir dann ein zweites problem lösen
dass weder durch individuelle
sparsamkeit noch durch politische zum
hilfeleistungen sei es jetzt über
steuern sei es über einmalzahlungen
sondern wenn es eine teuerung gibt die
so stark von den repliken energiepreisen
angetrieben ist wie die dann und dann
und dann haben wir ein und wir haben ein
angebotsproblem weil so weniger weniger
am markt ist dadurch die preise steigen
an den börsen an den anderen
energiebörsen dann ist es eigentlich
kontraproduktiv den leuten die gleiche
die gleiche menge an nachfrage zu
vergünstigen sondern ich muss die
nachfrage reduzieren und überlegungen
dazu persönliche solaranlagen diese ist
es dann ich glaube es ist ein bisschen
irre führenden leuten zu sagen hier soll
es die gleiche menge zum beispiel eine
energie konsumieren ihr könnt das
anderswo billiger das ändert nämlich
nichts an der nachfrage lage sondern es
ist glaube ich mindestens so wichtig und
ich glaube in der situation noch
wichtiger zu sagen wie kannst du in dem
fall tatsächlich nachfrage und das heißt
in dem fall konsum vermeiden weil das
ist für die individuelle lage völlig
klar wenn ich ein günstiger angeboten
sondern auch für die wirtschaft wenn ich
konsum vermeide nämlich energiekonsum
vermeide in einer lage in der ich ein
angebotsproblem habe dann stärke ich
durch ungebremste nachfrage dass man
könnte sagen die subventionierung von
von von einer gleichen nachfrage und dem
gleichen konsum wie bisher treibt
natürlich die preise ungemein in einer
situation in der das angebot klein
bleibt oder sich sogar noch verringert
sei es durch die kriegssituation sei es
durch sondern irgendwie auch da sind
termin spekulationen und auch träsch es
ist so wenn ich an der
nachfragesituation nichts ändere dann
habe ich in einer angebots krise
automatisch preisdruck das heißt da geht
es dann über das individuelle schon noch
ein stück hinaus